for my Davis's [ __ ] brew all right if
you're anything dark dark sounds good to
me [ __ ] okay this one I did I write
the last limo because magic compass well
that's like hello that was smoked on
Sunday too or no [ __ ]
so he grows this yeah that's from the
farm that we're part we partner much
forever we're endorsing different over
my sister and told me to try it for DVD
appearance a month they make these
pre-rolls advice today seventy one of
them is called sasquatch and they're
doing like a [ __ ] camp and I know he
has his father's watch a sasquatch
hoping to get shots you know you got me
people okay you [ __ ] never look yeah
no they want to talk to me I'm talking
to them I guess I don't know I still
tried to like see what they're up like
what they were about on their website
how did they find you that if I would
find you if you haven't got a bunch of
computers so I forgot much look suppose
we [ __ ] debt aka
what back [ __ ] should happen and we
are disconnected there for a minute but
Uncle Joe is back
what boxer those were changes with lien
[ __ ] that was no Sun there Luis Oh what
else
only five milligrams take you where it
gotta be
that'll take you where you need to be
you know I'm saying you eat one of the
[ __ ] stars a debt to see ya we're not
even actually living in action to drop
them but look what we got tonight Oh
Lord oh lord please favorite this [ __ ]
that's good that's good it'll be more
for Tom is Tuesday night going on
Wednesday we'll celebrate Memorial Day
still I got my [ __ ] stripes on game
plan I got the weed that killed all the
anger this is the [ __ ] that killed
Noriega sadness on you right now you're
gonna get a bumper this to someone I'm
alright can we do it
are you going over a depressing [ __ ] I
wish you can see Lee's face you sitting
there we're gonna show up here with
[ __ ] make wheel I know we think a
couple bomb is not one day that income
of this engine in the movie we thing you
want to do you want to vote too I want
three bond yeah you might set the people
return for me I want I want this [ __ ]
until Jesus hello
I want this [ __ ] they kill Noriega I
want I got to shoot a drag woman we
haven't even smoked that [ __ ] yet
because nobody wants to smoke some I
just [ __ ] you up is look if somebody
dies tonight I'm smoking weed and you
got a counter that weed you will sell it
tomorrow
in eight minutes wet signature you don't
want to [ __ ] that's regular and
pineapple Express you you want the [ __ ]
that kill somebody
let's really go looking to kill you have
to get me playing on me I'm right here
we're deep in [ __ ] blood and guts
whether it's the liquid acid whether
it's the [ __ ] you're paying yourself
maybe in the control room I don't know
this guy's Columbus did I think God put
on this planet to walk around and not do
anything good go to Starbucks and talk
nonsense with your friends about bad
company Larry is that what you think God
puts on this planet for me there's a guy
who j-3 74 years old right
serious guy he came for the show last
week today professor comes up and black
belt he goes
[Music]
you don't ever to him yet he want to
play salmon accessory qualities he's 70
[ __ ] for he goes to the Jitsu matches
in jujitsu because the three classes a
day thank you like kick man yeah he's
great he brings a [ __ ] cooler full of
food so they'll sit there for three
hours do roll and then eat protein he's
a genius and sometimes that's on the
other day some young kid said haven't
you gotta do it all over again what's
the one key advice you give me right now
being 74 years old he said savage looked
up Leo's keep [ __ ] I agree
keep [ __ ] [ __ ] it's Tuesday
night I'm saying
it's Tuesday [ __ ] night you got to do
what you got to do you got to wash your
ass it's the summertime nobody wants to
hang out with stinky ass people cuz she
is here I'm saying
your day blue those clouds Celia yeah
waiting [ __ ] around silly these
people amateurs amateurs they have no
[ __ ] idea
well Johnny's bringing to the table of
it look at this a container with no
label you see this container it's kind
of label we're going to contain it with
no way somebody's going down
somebody's going see you don't see me
you ready this is the one that killed
Bob Dylan I get off he's still alive
he's I see that the rate will go they
got it yeah
one day a week some [ __ ] musician
dies every week some [ __ ] musician
dies Olivia newton-john got diagnosed
with cancer came back 25 [ __ ] years
every with yeah yeah I love Olivia
newton-john [ __ ] cute little blonde
little hair then tell nobody Travolta
was a [ __ ] although she is in fact
she kept it to a South you know why
because she's Australian not a
blabbermouth like the rest of these
dirty [ __ ] walking around if that was
a regular [ __ ] dirty [ __ ] like from
st. Louis everyone own that [ __ ] not
sure Walter son take part time but she
said nothing he was sucking dick on the
set of grease I got no idea get him
saying that under men all I know is got
a thing hopelessly devoted to you
music maestro hold on one second Bleek
what's the story with the bump
I forget the chocolate another bond with
uncle Josh if you have two three there's
a three work on set Committee numbers
shortcoming well I don't come up with no
numbers when I'm with you because this
is goodness and I use you gotta do a
superset Mac is doing super cents for a
little green update I don't know to make
it a super sense like when you do curls
it's kind of ten curls pulling down and
I think two dumbbells and do hammer
curls the pump output blood more blood
into that area that's what we're doing
we're giving any open blood this is the
CrossFit of week this is what we're doin
care about both kinda clean ready let's
do this [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
stay right there stay right there I'm
going all right stay right there
bring on emails everybody knows you're a
savage exactly breathe out you know
breathe that even take doing it Aseema
genuinely listen to him and he knows I
mean I'm Rosa season cuz I'm looking to
me give me this one give me the [ __ ]
oh you tell you that are you then come
up negative Pakistan and not the one
feelings not even caught he covered it
with his hand I didn't cover nothing
let's go make a little cake with doing
super central super sent me I know I
told you I told you
tofu the people don't worry about the
people focus on the bun hold on right
there you go come on keep going
Oh your lungs come on let's go you guy
don't you go keep going keep going
let it loose let it loose let it loose
now let it loose
pick up that carburetor let that
[ __ ] loose there you go finish
that but looking at cafe au lait is that
something thing and [ __ ]
you're a soldier of the church we ain't
[ __ ] around no more look look we
letting all the smoke on for like
grandpa's [ __ ] that so I'm saying I'm
building me
I'm building [ __ ] copter you
understand me chocolate sunny stars
easily by five [ __ ] really laying out
of the park may have to do a 3,000
milligrams of Stars last Tuesday last
Wednesday where you try to prove in
concluding we don't [ __ ] around
we're professionals it that's why dr.
Spock dancing here's what I think these
people say named out but we got liquid
ass in here we got blotter acid Mattel
everything we're ready for war here you
know if it wasn't looking for Leo now is
it three money man bail come visit me in
the mood to lounge people give me the
kind of reefer like this but no label
later sign we always got a little bit
missing there's no label we brainy he
brought this in from Israel Israel in
the mountains of [ __ ] Israel this is
Jewish mother [ __ ] reefer ready yes
this is what the Krav Maga smokes for
breakfast you wanna [ __ ] this want to
[ __ ] around with you I love that Marilyn
it takes tremendous [ __ ] you in case
[ __ ] [ __ ] you and taste I don't give a
[ __ ] about taste if you want to see the
devil for that $20 give that 20 give
that reefer back and go back to that
[ __ ] say listen I want what
Joey smoking
I want the [ __ ] that makes you see for
what's going on with it how's that truck
very good you can open your eyes only if
I had a $20 billion open your eyes cuz
you know I love them I got a couple 20
I'll show it to I guarantee you open
your eyes real big you [ __ ] anyway
where he would clear this is what it's
all about you made that bunks with it
before I [ __ ] kill myself only it's
kind of a bum gets in rape another one
we gotta go mourn the super EXTREME yeah
the one transplant every week or
something you don't tell me about little
[ __ ] listen
save that [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] high times
this is uncle Joey time I'm gonna put my
own [ __ ] magazine every page is gonna
be me laying there with a cloud of smoke
that's gonna pay for hours for you
understand be confident and leak awful
in the corner a little scratch and sniff
the whole [ __ ] time I make my own
magazine like Ike Turner Home magazine
is [ __ ] I'm making my own movies I'm
writing my own books if I heard it's not
a role model out in 93 when [ __ ] she
went off the rails a little bit no no
she went off the rails like an 87 I
really started talking [ __ ] about a 10
so 93 i Tennyson [ __ ] and he hired a
publicist he was a dude small talk tour
about she told us [ __ ] story
now this is my side of the story issue
so he went to they did one in New York
and this girl told me about it she goes
you got to come down here because it's
gonna be a train wreck
she was I worked for the guy in between
him and his publicity company he hide
this big publicity come this is nineteen
ninety three ninety two so had to be
twenty five years ago and the first day
they had a downstairs in the lobby
they're like a couple couple people
showed up
a couple lose radios and [ __ ] TV
stations and he went out to have first
of all he was two hours late he was
smoking crack in the window picked him
up to the you know the whole [ __ ] be
like everything yeah he got on the car
took behind the podium and then I saw
like what's going on he's like matei was
going on I'm writing my own books I'm
making my own movies
he's like [ __ ] I never smacked on the
face no he what he was I guess I never
punched in the face I just knocked a
couple times like he was [ __ ] he
wouldn't stop they're like you know what
we have a good day we're gonna give you
a check back this is OK this is not
gonna work
[Music]
[Music]
listen you want a part even upper jaw
you better [ __ ] put that marine at
our thumbs up because we have [ __ ]
around it is like a button on the bottom
you're not telling me about that
shooting up your mouth [ __ ] cause I'm
Tanya I'm a professional we ain't got
time to be picking around wisdom stars
that going deeper and the message deep
right now that stars a peaceful universe
tone really is beautiful [ __ ] buds
ready this is this [ __ ] but here that
killed Lori Hagan is what it's called
oh gee Noriega throne of Israel you
understand me
next time you stopped by the Voodoo
Lounge I'll give you a take it out of
the [ __ ] safe you love this [ __ ]
you'll go Joey what the [ __ ] is that
it's the man with no name that's what's
called right you still got stars for you
[ __ ] never fear uncle Joey's
here we would call out that juggler I
got this conglomeration for you after
the chocolates i'ma leave already
and then we were just standing here look
at this conglomeration
Lucca Biskind inauguration we used to be
Lisa please effect that but you don't
get dreadful - he does nothing for
getting its prey free and malleable soon
yeah I don't get paid to do jokes I get
paid to get on a plane my job
description changes answers goodbye your
position he'll say what about your
position [ __ ] what about your
position uncle Joey here never fear I'm
going to take it to the next level
tonight the church ten minutes see
Leah's here tonight this [ __ ] well
[ __ ] around for you [ __ ]
Willie give you a lowdown on brief with
CBD oils and I would say people's cats
and [ __ ] like this I'll talk to you
people a few minutes youtube.com/ Sachs
Lee / Joey Diaz I'm [ __ ] a mumble like
Tiger Woods
come over here mumbling like Tiger did
the other night
I love 18 [ __ ] Viking and sure you're
gonna pass out you [ __ ] 18 vicodins
what the [ __ ] it's one every eight hours
if pain is needed [ __ ] I know that
thing my [ __ ] word now is I've read
those labels for years you understand me
anyway youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
don't forget flappers Thursday night
7:30 show quicken out yeah by 9:30
jumping up and down at [ __ ] the play
with the blades down the corner Barney's
Beanery over there you go over there and
eat some [ __ ] food you'll be up to
work early trust me anyway flap to 7:30
one hour working out with Joey Diaz ten
bucks what else you got to do for
[ __ ] 10 bucks with a scale like Joey
I got a notebook full of [ __ ] I gotta
try we might as well try it together
smoke a joint cheaper than a [ __ ]
movie and it's way better than movie
don't forget Thursday flappers
youtube.com slash c / Joey this who
loves you more than me nobody understand
what if this [ __ ] I love you almost
as much as you and look at you
[ __ ]
where's that Chuck we was supposed to
happen but I like waiting to live in
humans I'm sorry my management
partnership mafia malicious your bot I
think the [ __ ] itself exception
[Laughter]